ici amicaux live c'est vrai que les tirs
d'artillerie commence souvent à la
tombée du jour alors et bien on voit ses
habitants qui se dirigent vers les abris
à partir de l'heure du couvre feu nous
avons passé effectivement la nuit dans
l'un de ces abris dans le sous-sol est
d'un hôpital qui sert également de
refuge pour les habitants du quartier
nous qui arrive aux alentours de 7h dans
ce refuge alors ils discutent entre eux
jusqu'à tard dans la nuit vous voyez les
enfants qui jouent entre eux il y avait
il ya des gens qui ont tissé des liens
dans ces abris un certains dorment dans
ces abris depuis plus de dix jours vous
voyez les gens qui sont en silence qui
lisent des livres et c'est ce que nous
disait une dame qui dort dans cet abri
depuis plusieurs jours à nous disais
c'est le seul point positif c'est qu'il
y a une vraie solidarité entre nous
c'est qu'on fait connaissance qu'on se
rapproche de nos voisins pour les
hôpitaux et bien certains des patients
les plus sévères sont traitées
directement dans ses sous-sols donc il y
à toute une vie souterraine qui
s'organise vive s'entraider dans ses
sous-sols parce que nous disait un
médecin et bien il est beaucoup trop
compliqué de les faire descendre dans
les étages dès que la sirène retentit
un autre habitant nous disait cette nuit
cet abri il y avait environ une
cinquantaine de personnes il nous disait
il ya beaucoup moins de monde dans ces
abris depuis ces derniers jours pour une
raison très simple c'est que beaucoup
d'habitants ont